Nur noch einen Tag, dann war's
das für Hannelore Kraft:
nie mehr mit dem Peer durch
ihr Bundesland touren.
Verdammter Wahlkampf, schon jetzt
hatte sie keine Lust mehr dazu,
wie sollte das erst werden, wenn sie
selbst in vier Jahren
die Oberpflaume der SPD wäre.
Hannelore Kraft rülpst ein
atemberaubendes Crescendo
in den noch jungen
nordrhein-westfälischen Vormittag.
Sie ist es nicht gewohnt,
so früh am Morgen einen
halben Liter Bier zu schlenzen,
schon gar nicht an
Mettbrötchen und Frikadelle.
Aber es kommt einfach total
bodenständig rüber
und Peers Einsatz-Kommando
hatte auch gemeint:
Bei dem Publikum vom
Frühstücksfernsehen wäre die Szene
der absolute Megaknaller,
man müsste nachher nur
den Teil rausschneiden, wie
sie sich mit dem BVB-Schal
die Spucke aus der
Kinnbehaarung wischte.
Okay, Hannelore Kraft hat
verstanden, heute will sie
alles richtig machen, schließlich
hängt das Schicksal
der gesamten Sozialdemokratie an
ihrem hauchdünnen Speichelfaden -
sozusagen.
Hannelore Kraft hat in London
Wirtschaftswissenschaften studiert
und im Wahlkampf soll sie
für den schnöseligen Fischkopp einen
auf Bergarbeitermama machen?!?
Fehlte nur noch, dass diese
Parasiten-verseuchten Brieftauben
ihr auch noch das Kostüm vollkackten.
Noch drei Nummern zusammen
mit Peer für heute:
Einmal Schweine streicheln
bei irgendwelchen Katholen-
Honks im Münsterland,
dann die typische SPD-Wichsvorlage:
ein Foto mit zugestäubter Fresse
und einer Grubenlampe auf dem
gelben Plaste-Helm
und zuletzt noch ein Hausbesuch mit
diesen Vormenschen aus dem Sauerland.
Hannelore Kraft weiß,
dass in diesen Bildern
das Samenkorn gelegt ist für
ihre Kandidatur in vier Jahren.
Deshalb ist sie kurz vorm
Kotzreiz dennoch Profi genug,
um fürs Foto dem Peer
schelmisch eine Frikadelle
vom Pappteller zu stibitzen.